bonsoir à vous remercier d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
explosion de cas à mayotte comment
l'expliquer écoutez pour nous mais ce
sont clairement les et les autorités ont
attendu trop longtemps on a appris que
dominique voynet la directrice de la rs
a lancé une alerte le 5 janvier à paris
et on voit que la décision de
confinement n'a n'est intervenue que un
mois plus tard on a perdu un mois de
confinement qui aurait permis de
ralentir la propagation du virus le
préfet la directrice de la rs 1 ont
répété qu'ils ne voulaient pas fermer le
et proclamé le confinement pour protéger
l'économie clandestine protéger les
trafics et donc on se retrouve
aujourd'hui a constaté ce mur épidémique
que les médecins décrivent au chm qui
est complètement saturé des malades qui
sont envoyées à la réunion des
opérations et des traitements courants
qui sont annulés moi je rappelle quand
même et c'est important de le comprendre
mayotte c'est un désert médical
on ne peut pas comprendre que les
autorités découvrent la proximité avec
l'afrique du sud alors que les autorités
sud africaines ont lancé l alerte le 18
décembre les kwassa qui sont remplis de
comoriens qui entrent illégalement à
mayotte dont certains sont contaminés
continuent à arriver quotidiennement sur
les plages à mayotte
donc en fait toute la stratégie
sanitaire qui a été mise en place au
niveau national n'existe pas
effectivement à mayotte et on en paye
aujourd'hui le prix je rappelle que
l'année dernière il ya eu 40 % de
surmortalité à mayotte en craint le pire
parce que là ce qu'on vit est bien pire
que ce qui s'est passé l'an dernier au
début pour la première vague mayotte
avait été
relativement et je pèse mes mots il y en
avait été relativement épargnée avec
quand même 40 % de mortalité est là
cette fois on a une situation qui est
beaucoup plus alarmant parce que ce sont
des patients qui sont plus jeunes et il
y aurait eu le décès de quelqu'un qui
avait à peine 25 ans avec des personnes
qui ont entre 40 et 65 ans qui ont des
formes de détresse respiratoire hyper
importante et qui sont très nombreuses
l'hôpital nous dit qu'il ya environ une
dizaine de patients qui arrivent en
détresse on développe la médecine à
domicile le problème c'est que comme un
désert médical il ya très peu de
médecins de ville pas assez de soignants
et puis nos soignants ils sont aussi
épuisé un comme comme dans le reste du
pays
donc vous parler de l'afrique du sud
tout à l'heure pas très loin d'un
mayotte c'est vrai qu'à la crainte
d'avoir circulé le variant sud africain
notamment à mayotte ce quelles sont vos
informations à ce niveau en fait
évidemment on parle du variant sud
africain parce que ce sont les autorités
sud africaines qui ont observé les
variations comment dire au niveau de
l'évolution du du virus mais en réalité
le foyer épidémique qui a contaminé
mayotte île et aux comores voisines
et comme nos frontières sont des
passoires qu'on a tous les jours dd quoi
ça qui arrive avec des personnes qui
sont malades ou avec des personnes qui
sont contaminées qui ne passe pas
évidemment de tests puisqu'elle rentrer
illégalement sur le territoire et ben en
fait toute la stratégie de mettre la
france sous cloche pour la protéger de
l'infection ou de la propagation du
courant navires us quand vous avez le
chef de l'état le président macro qui
annonce qu on ferme les frontières du
territoire national c'est pas le cas à
mayotte
parce qu'il continue jusqu'à ce jour
allait avoir d entrée illégale sur le
territoire et qu'on est à seulement une
soixantaine de kilomètres du foyer
épidémique comoriens donc ça c'est un
vrai sujet il ya une réunion
diplomatique qui est prévue la semaine
prochaine entre la france et des comment
on espère que paris va hausser le ton et
va sanctionner les comores qui ne
collaborent pas malgré leur
engagements internationaux ça peut
remettre en cause le confinement qui est
décidée actuellement ses frontières
poreuses
la question de la santé publique c'est
pas de la pensée magique c'est pas juste
des déclarations quand vous avez
aujourd'hui dans un établissement
scolaire haqqani des combats qui ont
duré des batailles avec des bandes de
jeunes qui ont duré toute la journée
vous rendez bien compte que l'ordre
public n'est pas assurée à mayotte
quand vous avez les déclarations du
préfet du ministre ou même du chef de
l'état qui sont mises à mal par la
réalité qu'on constate sur le terrain
d'arrivée quotidienne de dizaines de
kwassa-kwassa qui rendent dans le lagon
comme s'ils étaient sur un lac est il
sans contrôle
quand on entend que le centre de
rétention qui procède aux expulsions
relâche dans la nature des étrangers en
situation irrégulière qui ont le coc
vide
on comprend que nous notre situation
sanitaire à ne peut pas s'améliorer tant
qu'on n'a pas réglé le sujet du contrôle
des frontières rapidement estelle
youssoufa la vaccination où en est elle
à mayotte
on imagine que ça doit être difficile de
d'acheminer le vaccin notamment failli
there biotech à cause des modalités de
conservation
oui parce que en fait il ya évidemment
la question qui reste posée qui entière
de savoir l'efficacité de ces vaccins
sur les variants sud africain mais on a
aussi deux variants britannique à
mayotte
donc ça ça reste quand même un vrai
point d'interrogation
on a entendu la directrice de la rs nous
dire que finalement files heures ce
n'était pas la meilleure option pour
mayotte et qu'il fallait attendre les
autres vaccins qui ne nécessitait pas
une chaîne du froid qui serait plus
difficile mais fondamentalement quand
vous avez seulement 912 de vaccins qui
sont livrés un mois après la métropole
pour commencer la campagne de vaccins de
vax de vaccination on voit bien qu'il ya
un vrai problème est qu'on a des
autorités qui ne prennent pas la mesure
de la
gravité de la situation à mayotte on
attend des mesures qui sont pas des
grandes déclarations mais qui change la
situation sur le terrain merci beaucoup
à vous installiez sauf la journaliste
indépendante est président du collectif
des citoyens de mayotte